Rolling Stone runs this headline they
say Speaker of the House Mike Johnson
admitted that he and his son monitored
each other's porn intake in a resurfaced
clip from 2020 whoa wow man that's gross
and weird isn't it wow that's what kind
of weird stuff is the Republican speaker
into what the hold on well let's just
listen because we have the
clip here here's what actually
happened Covenant eyes is the soft Ware
that I I've we've been using a long time
in our household and what it is it's
accountability software so uh men in a
church you know men's bible study groups
will do it that's how it's was presented
at promis Keepers but they also mention
hey when your kids become teenagers
especially if you have boys dads they're
talking to the guys at this event you
might want to think about doing this
with your sons it scans you you
obviously opt into it but it scans every
all the activity on your phone or your
devices your laptop tablet what have you
we do all of it and then it sends a
report to your accountability part so my
account accountability partner right now
is Jack my son right and so he's 17 so
he and I get a report of all the things
that are on our phones or all of our
devices once a week if anything
objectionable comes up your
accountability partner gets an immediate
notice I'm proud to tell you my son is
he's got a clean slate all right but but
we get we get a report and it says hey
no no uh activity of concern and it's
really really sensitive it'll pick up
almost anything it looks for keywords
Search terms and also
images oh
so sorry the actual story
is good
father discourages mortal
sin and sets a good example for his son
and then holds himself accountable in
front of his son so that his son knows
that he's not a
hypocrite subjects himself to the same
demands moral demands that he's making
of his son and allows his son to hold
him him accountable if he were to
violate them so so the actual story is
this man is a good
father not doing weird sex stuff at all
and discouraging his kids from doing
weird sex stuff and the absolute
degenerates these people at Rolling
Stone who I have to imagine have just
burned out their brains on such an
extraordinarily High degree of porn
consumption they the way they read that
is
the
Speaker of the House Mike Johnson
admitted as though he what is though he
regrets this or something is this is
some dark confession he's encouraging
this he is promoting this in a public
forum admitted that he and his son
monitor each other's porn intake uh
quite the opposite actually they monitor
each other's lack of porn intake because
this man is a good father by all
accounts he's well formed and he's
raising his son in a good way in a re
surfaced clip a res like we oh we had to
dig this one up I'm sure Mike Johnson
would talk about this on the floor of
the house this is great so the actual
story here is that the current
Republican speaker is an excellent
parent and the and the story is this is
weird or gross or evil in some
way woe to those who call good evil and
evil good amazing I I in a way I want to
give Rolling Stone the benefit of the
doubt I do suspect that on the physical
level their brains and perhaps on the
medical metaphysical level their souls
are so burned out by Vice and a failure
to
repent and an unwillingness to repent
that they just don't get it they don't
get that that's good that's you know
these Libs they say you should talk to
your kids about porn you should we
should have porn in elementary school
libraries we should encourage all sorts
of weird sexual behaviors uh no that's
the bad that's the bad creepy one that's
the bet if you want to be a good parent
do what Mike Johnson's doing right now
go to goodranchers.com use promo code
noes you know there's a lot at stake
this November so don't be
chicken and shop at the grocery store
like usual instead you should Seafood
your way to I lost I lost the thread go
to good ranchers they're Black Friday uh
your way sale is live it's something you
do not want to miss they've got great
meat puns I've got great meat funs
they've got even better meat this
November you get to pick your favorite
meat to get free for a year pick a year
of free steak free salmon free chicken
or free bacon when you subscribe to any
box right now better yet when you
subscribe to any box on goodranchers.com
you not only get a free gift of meat
worth up to $480 you also get 15 bucks
off with code
nolles I don't know how their finances
work at good ranchers I don't know how
they Source meat this good it's just
phenomenal I eat good ranchers multiple
times a week when I'm not traveling on
the road it it's just magnificent
quality I've never had anything like it
the prices are unbelievable and then
they keep locking in your price and
giving you stuff for free and I don't
know how they do it uh but you should
sign up while you still can claim your
year of free meat 15 bucks off in free
shipping with my code nolles kwes at
goodranchers.com good ranchers is the
number one place to get all American
Beef Pork Chicken and Seafood that is
promo code nesg goodranchers.com
goodranchers American Meat delivered
right now go to medishare.com
as a dailywire listener you are not just
informed you're engaged and you're
handsome too you value freedom and
personal responsibility that's why you
got to check out Medishare Medishare is
a community- based approach to
healthcare that lines up with the
principles you believe in your beliefs
matter with Medishare your Healthcare
dollars won't be used for medical
procedures that don't line up with your
beliefs Medishare is the highest rated
Healthcare sharing Ministry with a
30-year proven track record it's not
health insurance it's a community of
400,000 Believers committed to caring
and sharing with one another members
save up to 50% or more on their monthly
healthcare costs and member satisfaction
surveys show that they like Meda share
much more than health insurance why
because it works for a limited time
dailywire listeners will receive a $150
gift card when they join metashare to
find out more go to medishare.com Michel
M that is medishare.com
Michel M AEL and you will receive a
$150 gift card when you join Medishare
terms and conditions apply really really
sad story out of Britain just after I
flew out of London just the day I think
it was the very day I flew back from
London this past week there was a
massive Pro Palestine protest in London
there were also some pro- British
protesters so wow there were people
waving the Palestine flag there were
people waving the Union Jack and the
people waving the Union Jack were
British milit Ary veterans and the cops
came up and told them that they couldn't
wave their flag they didn't say that to
the pro Palestine protesters they said
that to the British military veterans
here's
[Music]
why you can hold it you can hold it you
can wave it it's just we don't not
causing any sort of issues in the
barriers have have your flags just not
on the barriers that's
it and yet when they March down with
hundreds of Palestinian Flags you won't
say
out's way more of
them there's way
more no it's displaying on these bar
barriers I know but he's driving a motor
we're talking about these barriers it's
not about the motors I'm just talking
about the
barriers they was flying the other day
didn't do nothing did you I wasn't there
no you wasn't there but you didn't and
the veterans some of them wearing their
full military fatigues
few at least the the younger cop or the
cop on the
left he's saying yeah yeah it's not
fair but there's more of those guys than
there are of us so we can't put them in
their place Flags we're going to put you
in your place cuz there aren't that that
many British military veterans out
here
very very sad story that's democracy for
you I
guess that's that's he's saying yeah
we're overruled by the mob and so your
own country British veterans who have
risked your lives to defend this island
nation you don't get the right to
political speech even the most basic
political speech which is to wave your
flag and support your country but those
guys who are foreigners who are pledging
their allegiance to a foreign it's not
even a foreign Nation it's a foreign
wouldbe Nation but at the very least
it's a foreign people they get the
political rights that you risked your
lives for the rights that you do not get
yourselves boy what a great clip that
was now hey I know what you're thinking
that's a nice Studio on the road Michael
I know it is it looks pretty nice the
second thing you're thinking is I ought
to subscribe yes you should ring the
bell we'll see you next time